this is small morning world famous
expert in silap one of the deadliest
martial arts in
history today he's going to show me how
it works hit hit hit hit hit and why
it's so
effective and it all starts with the
knife most people they would go like
this and Go slash or they go one here
they go Bo boom we learn how to defend
against common attacks don't try to go
attack yeah here go oh really but that's
very common everyone does that uh yeah
but uh we're not here to drill the drill
is to create skill so when you fight you
use the skill not the drill so I got
boom boom now it's your turn you pass my
hand boom boom back hand and then you
come back oh okay so this is the drill
so now if I take it as an
application so if you give me back hand
yeah I have the pass and if I don't want
to push you I just want to break your
rist is here so you didn't disarm me you
just attacked me yeah I don't need to
disarm you really because if I'm focused
on yeah then that is seminar content ah
because it's impressive if my life is
onl here go for a Punch Yeah here see
that yeah I know you are yeah and I know
where you are so the goal is hit hit hit
hit hit I know where you are oh so
you're slapping my shoulder instead of
my head yes thank you very much so that
I can um simulate a real reaction yes
but if I go like this react for me oh
yeah it's too slow you react correctly
then I have this see the control then
one
yes we aim for the liver the ribs okay
the neck back of the head right here
yeah growing because if you're the guy
who's holding the knife you think you
are in control and I'm the victim yeah
so I want to change that role let just
like that so you want to become the
attacker yes so most people you go and
then you come back again I'm too focus
on this yes we don't focus on that we
focus on rather than do this to throw
you I use the skin to throw
you yes
wow if I'm not wearing this you have to
grab thisin yeah and I'm not I'm not
using my nail if I do this and you pull
yeah they gone yeah uh basically you
will have a scar or you will get um a
nail scratch but it's gone so I want to
make sure I fold your skin yep in my
yeah can we get a closeup of how you
fold the skin just so people can see
that so basically I'm here yes I pin and
I fold it in M yeah so it's not it's not
this you're using my skin like my karate
uni yeah yeah
yeah wow I've never seen that before so
I'm here I move you around yeah and this
one
oh okay wait he just ripped the skin on
my yes ribs yeah is this one same thing
you roll it Forward
yeah because we don't have geese no so
you your skin
is yeah your skin is the that was the
skin inside of my thigh what are the
biggest mistakes you see people doing
when it comes to night defense well um
my opinion yes yeah I'm not saying
everybody else is wrong right so
basically everybody tells you to run
away from a knife attacker but silat
takes it one step further usually if you
bring a knife you'll also have other
people bringing a stick bringing a
pitchfork people have a mob mentality
mob mentality yeah so this is why your
first goal is to run when you see knife
but make sure you injure someone first
first really bad yeah so that that's
like the person they need to yeah so
they will take care of that when you run
away I see so you don't just run because
if you run yeah yeah then they will
chase you until you go out of breath so
this is why everything that you do is
always yeah when you come come yeah here
see right
hi wait we're doing a drill and I've
never done this before no no how did
that happen cuz I'm giving you this yes
I'm not giving you this so if I give you
this I don't give you options I always
want you to be on the outside of my hand
but you don't know that mhm yes so you
attacking me because you want a specific
response from me that you can then take
advantage
of yeah see if you put your hand up yeah
like so that was my natural reaction was
just to protect myself I just hit it
yeah oh you're hitting my arm on purpose
yes I see that coming up that's what I
want bam then elbow I will I'm looking
see I'm looking for theaction yes so he
just hit my bicep and it really hurts
yes so if you come to attack me yeah so
boom see see that yeah clear my hand
underneath clear my hand from underneath
like this yeah see yeah I you
back yes but if you take I'm always
pushing you I'm always pushing you there
I'm always pushing you there if I'm not
pushing you yeah I'm hitting you I'm
hitting you or I'm dragging you I am
never stable I'm always moving somehow
yes because my goal is to push you off
the bridge oh so it's like we're
fighting on a bridge okay many villages
in Southeast Asia were built on water
this is reflected in the techniques of
silat if I'm a nice person yeah I just
push you off the bridge okay if I'm a
sadistic person I'll break your ankle
first or I break your ribs before I push
you off the bridge okay so that's the
thing so this is why when you come to
attack me yeah yeah come yeah so this is
the water now oh yeah yeah if to grab my
neck yeah and then to stab me I push you
this way yeah exactly so
this yeah that foot sweep was
interesting can you show that again yeah
yeah yeah so how does that okay if I'm
here yes boom I disarm you first yes you
attack okay I attack yeah I what I do is
to col this that yes now I take the foot
seat yeah I want to stand up I want to
Anchor you yeah so you're pushing anchor
so there's two ways of doing it I anchor
you down or as you busy here I anchor
you there boom boom then yep so this is
why if I do a sweep imagine I sweep your
and you fall down yeah that will just
make you angrier right because there's
no pain yeah and I can still stab you
exactly yeah and then that's dangerous
yeah yeah so the thing is I want to make
sure I put pain first so imagine if I
hit you in the liver or I break your
ribs yeah then I push in the water yeah
how you going to swi that's the old
mindset yes so you are you have empathy
yeah but only to certain degree M yes
yes so you're okay to break his ribs
yeah but if if he dies I didn't kill you
you brown because this is a traditional
martial art yes but this is why our goal
is uh do the drill yeah to have skill
yes but when you fight you use the skill
not the drill so do you always want to
be on an angle your power line is like a
train p p p right so you want to make
sure you go from here I go here you go
from here I go here you go boom clear
see thrust thrust oh thrust okay
yeah and those hits would be in the face
in real life yes yeah because even I
don't need to hit you imagine this your
face now okay I keep on yeah yeah you'll
go you you have a reaction but in
training it's to learn how to play yes
see back hand back hand oh that's why
I'm guiding you I'm guiding you it
doesn't matter what I do cuz you always
have a response because I'm the one who
baiting you to attack me from which
angle exactly and the thing is I can
read from your shoulder for example any
angle any angle any angle okay see any
angle just too much of a
Tegra yeah o now want to pull now I know
that come oh up
yeah so when you
come here that
here here so once I'm here I drop there
then I'm
here what I'm trying to do here is oh
sorry microphone so what I'm trying to
do here is hit you boom right yes but I
change it into ah or yeah I hit you here
right and I change it to thank you
yes boom sorry about that yeah yeah boom
yes yeah elbow to the face boom if
you're not flexible I use my forearm if
you're flexible I use this now as I do
this as I dislocate it straightened out
no now I take this pull I push it down
then there your grin and my arm hurts in
five different places at least from all
those punches Sor about that but that
just means it's effective we try not to
claim that because different people got
different realities yeah some people
when they take drugs some people when
they have alcohol they will not feel it
so this is why you hit as much as
possible until something breaks yes so
if I break you at least something worked
yes so this is why when people said yeah
What mo he attacked you once but you hit
him 10,000 times yeah it's because
you're not down yet yeah exactly I you
until you're on the floor what's your
best piece of advice for people out
there who want to get better at knife
defense drill drill drill again our
concept is drill makes skill yes so you
don't do an empty drill if you're just
doing a drill but there is no
application and there's no understanding
behind the drill then it's useless for
example there's only one right you have
the slash yeah and then this slash yeah
and then every other angle is just
variation so you could hit me here yeah
that if you hit me here yeah if you hit
me here you go here yeah see yeah same
and what I want is I always want to hit
close to your spleen or to your liver
okay because I want you to collapse M
once you collapse now you're lower than
me which makes it an easy fight you just
hit
downwards thank you so much it was very
interesting and thank you so much thank
you hit subscribe if all of you enjoyed
that